Let's get right into it.
Normally, I would waste a ton of time at the
top of the show talking about the show, but
we actually have too much show today.
So let's just get right into it.
I'm a little worried that there are too many
people on the left who are not seriously looking
at Joe Biden's proposals and platform, particularly
his economic proposals, not looking at them
seriously enough and giving credit where credit
is due for what?
Guess would be the most progressive economic
platform of an American president in decades
and decades.
And I would argue even going beyond the high
marginal tax rates of Eisenhower's administration.
I'll explain why and a little bit.
There's a very good piece in MarketWatch called
Liberals aren't giving Joe Biden credit for
a radical tax plan that goes after the indolent
rich.
The article is by Nick Buffi.
We're linking to it on YouTube.
I encourage you to read it.
And the article accurately points out, as
I've been pointing out for months, that there
is a contingent of the left that is branding
Joe Biden as sort of like the ultimate centrist,
the epitome of the Democratic candidate who
is almost a Republican or would have been
a Republican in times past.
I think that that could not be further from
the truth.
Now, I've said this phrase, it would be the
most progressive economic platform in modern
political history.
And there were people writing me saying, David,
it's meaningless because it's 2020.
What's how is that meaningless?
It's accurate.
Okay.
You can say times have changed and our expectations
have moved to the left, and that's a good
thing.
And therefore, it is also a good thing if
our elected officials are following the movement
of the country politically.
And the concern for me is coming partially
from I think that there are some on the left
who are just ideologically blinded.
And then there are others who just aren't
looking at the proposals.
So let's focus in on the tax proposals that
Joe Biden has.
Separate yourself from ideology.
And separate yourself from what would be the
perfect and analyze what is Joe Biden's platform?
Joe Biden would raise the corporate profit
tax and establish what is effectively a minimum
tax for corporations similar to the alternative
minimum tax that people have had since individuals
have had since 1969.
That is radical in a context where both parties
have allowed these zero tax dollar status
quo of corporations to perpetuate itself.
Joe Biden would eliminate deductions for high
income earners.
Joe Biden would repeal most of the Trump tax
cuts and increase taxes on fossil fuel emissions.
So Joe Biden would uncap starting at four
hundred thousand dollars.
The 12 percent tax for Social Security.
That is absolutely massive.
I actually don't think for a moment I'm going
to imagine it's not that people don't care,
it's that people don't understand the magnitude
of that.
You would see a CEO who earns ten million
dollars a year go from paying a zero point
two percent effective Social Security tax
to a 12 percent effective Social Security
tax.
That is a massively radical proposal, which
you will see all sorts of people fight tooth
and nail to prevent from becoming a reality.
And then Joe Biden would take those revenues
and reinvest them in raising Social Security
benefits for the poor.
That's exactly the type of policy that a Bernie
Sanders type would put in place.
There are hundreds of thousands of seniors
who would be immediately pulled out of poverty
as a result of that policy without it costing
the middle class a penny.
Some say a dime.
I say a penny.
As we know, capital gains is something that
allows the super rich who don't work to pay
less as an effective tax rate than many people
who do work capital gains, long term capital
gains taxed at a far lower rate than earned
income for the rich.
Joe Biden has proposed eliminating that lower
capital gains rate on dividends and long term
capital gains for everybody making above a
million dollars per year.
If you combine that with raising the top tax
rate back to close to 40 percent, that is
a combination of proposals from Joe Biden,
which would nearly double the average tax
rate for non working millionaires.
The Tax Policy Center has analyzed this proposal
and has found that three quarters of Joe Biden's
tax increases would fall on the one percent
on the top one percent.
And a lot of that remaining 25 percent would
fall on the top two to four percent.
This is serious stuff.
This is serious, radical stuff.
The people that then come in and say, well,
he'll never get it done.
But hold on.
That that's not just Joe Biden.
Every president has trouble getting done what
they want to do.
And you would have to apply that exact same
standard, that exact same logic, that exact
same caveat.
To Bernie Sanders, you can say, well, it's
not left enough.
OK, but say that and recognize that it would
be the most progressive economic policy for
a sitting president for a long, long time.
There will be people who come in and say,
but the top marginal tax rate was up in the
90s during Dwight D. Eisenhower presidency.
Yes.
But the amount of loopholes available at that
time.
And remember, the alternative minimum tax
was not put in place until 1969.
So prior to that, even with these high sticker
tax rates under Eisenhower, the very rich
were rarely paying anything close to that
because of the amount of loopholes and because
of the lack of what's called the alternative
minimum tax.
So you can critique Joe Biden in saying he
doesn't go far enough.
For example, Joe Biden wants to reinstate
some of those state and local tax deductions
that Donald Trump got rid of.
There is no doubt that there are sort of medium
wealthy and super wealthy people in blue states
that lost some significant deductions when
Trump capped state and local tax deductions.
And yes, both the Democratic and Republican
Party are beholden to donors.
And that is something Joe Biden wants to reinstate,
but contrasted with the magnitude of the other
things that he's proposing to do.
So criticize Joe Biden for not going far enough
contextualized that we have two very corporate
parties that control politics in this country,
do all of that stuff.
But let's not be blind because of ideology
or laziness or lack of curiosity.
These are some pretty radical proposals here.
And whether or not Joe Biden can get it done,
that's a different question.
Trump hasn't gotten done the things he promised
Bernie would not be able to get done, the
things he wanted to do.
Elizabeth Warren would have had I mean, I
don't know how you pass a wealth tax.
I really don't.
But we have to judge by what the platforms
are.
And this is very serious stuff.
In in any case, you are going to have no opportunity
if Donald Trump gets another four years.
This is not, you know, the lesser of two evils.
There is clearly a better option here.
And it is not a small margin.
It is a dramatic margin between what Donald
Trump wants to do and has done on taxes and
what Joe Biden, his proposal proposing.
Just
the facts, my friends.
the facts.